[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai eu des candidats agitée sur le
plateau mais là on est à mille euros
quand même voilà dans les yvelines on
peut dans les radios allez-y allez-y et
on mélange bien ça renforce encore en
corner mais le voir affoler les foules
[Rires]
mais c'est quoi mon sac
on continue alors c'est pas vous trouver
un petit mélange désiré je me dois du
réseau
51 51
c'est hallucinant si c'est ça c'est
énorme
parce que c'est quand même c'est quand
même mieux car bien fait plus tard on me
dit souvent je ressemble à ma demande
l'arrêt rendu hier à kad merad [ __ ]
c'est incroyable et c'est quand tu
parles habitat si c'est toi c'est génial
allez on fait un dernier mot enfin
dernier parce que j'ai besoin quand même
d'être d'être fixé couilles c'est courir
c'est aux usa ll es quoi mais oui c'est
toi ya d'ailleurs reparle un petit peu
la foufoune bon ça y est c'est beau
cyril quoi ces bouffons sors de ce corps
cyril été reconnu à temps je vérifie à
temps c'est pas je te jure si c'est pas
possible
monsieur bah non c'est qui bah je sais
pas moi je me suis à leur écoute quoi
bientôt célébrant demain glace et
gênante en débattant b-spec walla
maintenant on attend la nation vous
tirez vous de karité milan ac après fred
ajouté
calme-toi chaîne non non mais là ça qui
nous qui votons cyril hanouna
[Musique]
du coup
c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
picot gt gt à temps j'étais au maire des
thierry beccaro la production à john
eledjam qui fait est exceptionnel
environnants et un patrie alors est-ce
qu'on peut revoir juste coup de karaté
surpasser 40 fois ce week-end faut le
revoir il faut leur bas
regardez ça c'est après afin d'ajouter
[Applaudissements]
je me bats qu'en soit le téléphone on
sait qui se nourrit qu il désigne un
combat c'est un comédien john agent qui
travaille chez nous depuis maintenant
quatre sorcières merci énormité était
dense audard et je n'ai jamais dit il
avec moi partout avec moi sur l'émission
de canal aussi que vous avez vu puisque
vous avez adoré vous démarquer mais non
je suis désolé là j'ai vraiment vu je
peux vous raconter toute l'histoire mais
je reconnais réguillon de plein vent et
bon à lembras réforme